we have so many little legal battles
that we have to fight on an ongoing
basis
that people never hear about the issue
becomes when you can no longer actually
uh do your work or run your business and
with facebook this has been going on for
a long time
a lot of back and forth and then the
biggest independent election stream
um ever you know in this election that
we were we were doing a 15 million
people watching
uh that's not including whatever numbers
on facebook that vanished
um was removed and by the way it's still
up on youtube there aren't there isn't
even a soft copyright claim
and facebook never gave us any reason
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
comedian a podcaster
and host of louder with crowder on blaze
tv
steven crowder welcome back to the
reuben report
for the first time since april of 2016.
april 2016. well i've had you on my show
way more times than that so
thank you at some point we have to have
an equity on your show
dozens of times but somehow literally i
mean this is almost five years man
well i think you always wanted me to do
it you always wanted to have people
physically in studio and now with
the covid you'll take what you can get
and so thanks for having me dave
yeah it is good to have you uh you are
doing a first here on the reuben report
i have never had a guest
on the show before who requested to come
on the show
with their lawyer and if i'm not
mistaken that is your asian lawyer
sitting right next to you uh bill
richardson why why did you bring your
lawyer no hold on a second hold on a
second he's first he's half asian
and bill richardson is the governor of
new mexico this is a half asian bill
richmond but closely
bill richmond wait did i say bill
richardson yeah and actually
there is a little bit of a resemblance
so there is a little bit of a
resemblance
one for sure the shape of the head i
mean sometimes my wife even mistakes me
and calls me bill richardson if i
had a little bit too much chipotle so i
get it
no i just had him on well he's on the
show quite a bit uh and so it's
different from having
you know a lawyer on just saying don't
say that can't say that um
since he often acts like a co-host and
also to make sure that i don't screw up
since what we're talking about is
you know we've talked about this a lot
of a lot of conservatives out there sort
of
there's a little bit of sometimes crying
wolf where a post was removed and so oh
i'm gonna go to war with facebook but
since it's an actual
suit filed that um could prove to be a
landmark situation
he makes sure that you know i don't just
fly by the seat of my pants
okay well half asian bill richmond it's
good to
have you here and you know what crowder
i was going to do some personal stuff
with you but let's let's shove it
let's just dive right into this thing
because the the big tech censorship
thing i mean this is the issue of the
day it's like
it's not a issue it is the issue because
it's our only way to communicate at
least
right now and uh you're you're not happy
with
youtube you're not thrilled with twitter
but you're really not happy with
facebook huh
well you know what's funny is actually
uh probably the the obviously the people
with whom i would have the
the most grievances would be youtube
right sorry guys about the vox
apocalypse i didn't intend for that
um but yeah thanks for that by the way
yeah i know you know
guilty um but facebook has been going on
for a long time and here's the thing
i just want to do my show i just want to
do my work bill knows this he's been on
retainer for a long time
we have so many little legal battles
that we have to fight on an ongoing
basis
that people never hear about the issue
becomes when you can no longer actually
do your work or run your business and
with facebook this has been going on for
a long time
a lot of back and forth and then the
biggest independent election stream um
ever you know in this election that we
were we were doing 15 million people
watching
that's not including whatever numbers on
facebook that vanished
um was removed and by the way it's still
up on youtube
there aren't there isn't even a soft
copyright claim and
facebook never gave us any reason and
then after that started throttling the
page saying that this page can only be
viewed by your fans and
never gave us any reason and this you
know this is a long time coming because
to give you an idea this dates back to
um you know i've been doing this for a
long time and
when people talk about folks out there
who do this for their money you can go
back in 2009 where i was doing videos on
youtube with a blue bed sheet
there was no money there were no
conservatives online it was really just
sort of me out in the middle of the
desert
and i was very unlikable very punchable
face rightfully so jason priestly
sideburns people can go back and see it
but facebook early on you know i always
uh they approached me about advertising
on facebook and so we always spent a
little bit of money to run
ads you know on facebook early on to
kind of grow the page
and we established a business
relationship and then at one point
um for some reason out of the blue they
said that i was i i hadn't paid facebook
for two weeks worth of ads
that was delinquent on payment but
here's the thing they continued
accepting money for ads
every week thereafter so they accepted
money for ads all the way up until this
two-week period
said i didn't pay and then still had the
same method of payment the same card and
bank account on file and took money
after that
and so uh this is actually where
half-asian pill comes in
then there was this article that came
out an end gadget about um
this was a facebook gizmodo i always
forget them gizmodo the verge end gadget
whatever you know another cycle
it's all the same well they claim to be
text sites but they write you know about
uh about uh how uh men can have periods
too one of those sites
so it was uh talking about how pages
were being throttled by facebook and
they had this sort of screen grabbed
from behind the scenes and included ted
cruz
for president chris kyle foundation
breitbart and yours truly
and i thought i wonder if this relates
to something going on behind the scenes
with the payment issue well here's the
thing
i sent patient phil my my uh chats you
know your customer service chats with
facebook you know
um not only were they saying that my uh
account had
could be removed and my payment actually
so i could be in delinquency they'd
potentially send this to creditors um
but uh
what had happened was i sent a physical
check finally
payable to you to facebook in wherever
it is
palo alto one of those places they
deposited it
i had the receipt of them depositing the
check
and they were going to remove my page
that week and potentially send this to
creditors and still claiming that i
hadn't made the payment
the only way to remedy the situation and
it just happened to coincide
gizmodo engadget gizmodo gizmodo was uh
to have my lawyer reach out to them
there was no other way
i didn't want to do it i sent a check by
snail mail
which they deposited and they still were
going to try and pipe me so
all right that's how we met so before we
get too too into the weeds on
on all of the league no well there's a
lot of interesting stuff here and you
know i've been saying and we've talked
about it many times
that you have to fight the big tech
front in many ways you have to fight it
with
you know by building tech you have to
fight it by uh legal means whatever way
you can fight it i think you have to
fight it
but bill when you get the call from
crowder and he's like all right let's
let's do this let's do this with
facebook with any of these other
companies
i think a lot of lawyers would be like
no i just don't want to deal with the
headache i don't want to deal with the
massive amounts of lawyers that they
have the
the millions and millions and it's not
even millions of millions it's just
the endless amount of money that they
have to fight me
you're under shooting that a little bit
i mean zuckerberg hasn't seen a million
in probably a decade and a half you're
talking about
many many billions so yeah exactly so so
what is it about
about you that uh makes you want to work
with a guy like this and get into
the fight you're crazy yeah it's it's a
combination of
of one being crazy but also being
convicted of of the the values that go
into
when businesses need to treat people
right so when steve and i first met we
had never had a conversation before we'd
never talked about anything
at any point whatsoever a mutual
connection brought us together
they had tried to reach out to other
lawyers about trying to get this to
happen back in 2016 when this originally
occurred and i'm pretty sure you thought
it was foolish yet
i definitely thought it was spam or
craziness or
you know there you get a lot of calls as
a lawyer uh about certain cases and
you're just not sure about whether
they're any good
but when you started to put together
these facts it was at first hey you know
i
i wonder what's going on with this check
and then when the gizmodo article hit
you really realize that this is
something much larger than just a
accounting snafu
or a company deciding that they don't
particularly like a certain creator
it becomes much more nefarious than that
to the point of even with regards to
that gizmodo article there were senate
investigations and other things and this
is back
in 2016 before everything that we're
hearing in the last couple of years and
especially the last couple of months
regarding section 230
and the and really the new rally and
war path that facebook has been on
against creators
bill what would you say to the people
that would say hey
they're private companies they can do
whatever they want they can work with
whoever they want if they want to cut
you off if they want to shut you down
they have every right to do it i say
you're right
and they're still wrong because we're
pro-business but anti-fraud
america has been built on having
companies and people individually you
can contract with someone
and you can say hey we're going to do
certain things where i'm going to
operate cleanly you have statutes in
almost every state to protect
against anti-competitive behavior and
unfair and deceptive trade practices
and what you have from facebook is
exactly that because what they're trying
to do
and what they have been doing is saying
hey go create
for us create content we don't know how
to create content but we need you to
create that content
bring your people bring your followers
and with them comes the most valuable
thing
it's not really the eyeballs and ears
those are a byproduct it's the data
it's the data points that they can use
to sell the advertising everyone knows
that you know when you sign on for the
free product
you're the product but in this part
that's where the fraud is
because they're saying that we have a
platform where we uniformly
and non-discriminatorily and without
political bias enforce
our policies they even said that back in
2016 in defense to the senate letter
they said
no no no no no no no we never engage in
political viewpoint discrimination
despite what this whistleblower
employee has said despite what our
written handbook says about
these particular names and they sit in
front of congress as recently as last
year saying
no no no no we do not engage in that but
when you look at the actual pattern and
practice of who's getting shut down
who's getting throttled
despite the popularity of that content
despite the fact
that we have a country who's craving
certain values and viewpoints even if
they disagree
to at least hear them and disagree with
them you know that that's what's
happening this isn't about saying
oh i don't want to i don't want you as a
business owner to control who comes into
your business or who uses your platform
it's about saying that if you promise a
product that says it's going to be open
that it's going to be enforced in a
certain way
and you publish those policies you just
have to stick by them
yeah yeah and i think too crowder what
would go ahead
i think something too is you know bill's
always known that approaches as a
business owner
you know this when people see me
complain about something publicly you
know we we do a deep platform this
campaign or something like that's
because the fight has come to my
doorstep
i want to be able to run my program and
run my business
and we even said look look if you have
different rules from what we've been
told
tell us what they are now that's one
thing that happened at least at that
time of the vox adpocalypse where they
said okay
uh these videos need to be removed you
need to change your shirt and your merch
store which
was different they added guidelines
again sorry uh because i hadn't violated
any but then i said okay
your sandbox your rules understood with
facebook
they still haven't given any there's no
answer no reply
no reason for removing the biggest
election stream that's ever taken place
in an online platform by the way more
people were watching and i don't say
this to
to brag i mean you know we've talked
about this for a long time a lot of
people go out there and try and tout
their numbers i want the content to
speak for itself
more people were watching us than brian
williams and cnn combined
and facebook gave no reason to this day
zero justification for it at a certain
point
you have to know what the rules are
didn't we didn't they just so was it
friday
they just yeah now they just totally
demonetize the page which is fine we
should what
what was the reason listed none none
whatsoever i've invested over the years
since 2009 to that
we're talking about millions of dollars
into growing a business i mean
if you build a uh if you build a
building you know for whatever it's a
coffee shop a pizza parlor
and then someone comes in and says by
the way we're taking back the foundation
no i paid for that
and we agreed to that and if you change
the rules well first off there's some
legality there and then
tell me what the new rules are do i need
to pay for updates to the foundation
what do you have to corner the building
um they haven't given us any answers so
this is the only option available to me
not the first what would you guys say to
all of the media matters people
and the vox people and the daily beast
people who no doubt
will be watching this and they will say
but wait a minute crowder and your half
asian lawyer
when we look at the top 10 you know
drivers of traffic
to facebook pages you know usually four
out of ten have something to do with ben
shapiro
three of them are the blaze and you know
then there's one lefty thing
how could that how could that then be uh
the censorship of conservative voices
that's actually that's in spite of
facebook's policy
now we don't know because we don't have
access to the information algorithms
which are kept more secret than the coke
formula or
was it the 52 herbs and spices to the
colonel's chicken
but i will say this you know people used
to use this argument a lot about about
michael phelps
they would say well he eats uh three big
macs every day and he used to eat a
bunch of mcdonald's and this kind of
stuff and people say so that
therefore that must be the diet of
champions no he has the wingspan of an
albatross and a size 19 triple wide shoe
and so he can get away with eating
mcdonald's and still being
the best swimmer in the world because of
god-given athletic
capabilities i would say as it relates
to conservative content
listen the left has had all of maine abc
nbc cbs cnn msnbc
fox news really up until recently being
the only one
new york times washington post
everything right places you just
mentioned daily beast
vox right and these places are all owned
by multinational uh uh
media conglomerates like we've been in
tussles with
disney nbc is it then or is it disney
abc
uh nbc universal target.com viacom all
of them
never lost any of them um and so i think
that a lot of people go online for the
same reason this show has been as
successful as it is
for something that is an alternative
point of view alternative to what
everything else and so the fact that
people are
craving truth and information that they
cannot find
anywhere on their television dial um
that
conservatives shouldn't be faulted for
that it's just that the left listen
they've had
every other platform and they're not
nearly as competitive
uh here on facebook right now so just
just because they're more successful
doesn't mean that that's because
facebook's favoring them
and they're st and they're shoot so to
jump off of that dave real quick is
is really what it comes down to is that
the in spite of argument is very true
it's not about
how much is actually being shown it's
how much would have otherwise been shown
if you had enforced your
policies correctly and if at the end
facebook's one of their arguments one of
their defenses might be
our platform sucks people don't like it
that's why we're not getting that much
views that's why the streams aren't
doing as well uh you know our stuff just
broke down
we have no reason like it's just we're
actually really bad at what we do
that might be one of their defenses so
but ultimately it's about what should
have been
not about what they're actually
providing despite the fact that there
are numerous
conservative platforms and voices that
are getting good traction to spike the
policies
it's nonetheless doesn't speak to the
second point which is the individual
question about certain voices
there are certain voices that have
gotten more attention
in a bad way from the powers that be
whether it's youtube twitter or facebook
and steven is one of those when you look
back at the 2016 gizmodo article
that example there was based on only
having four names of all the
conservative voices out there at the
time
you had rush you had daily wire you had
shapiro you had all these other names
that were out there you were out there
one of the names that was out there
maybe not
fully in the conservative sphere at that
point but when you have all those names
and only a few are targeted you have to
ask the question of why and so our
lawsuit is not about
saying that there's this widespread top
to bottom
every single person is there saying they
hate conservatives what it's about is
saying
if you can bend the rules without giving
full business disclosure if you can
commit
fraud that is anti-competitive one media
company
complaining to another media company to
shut down a third media company
if all of that is legal then you don't
have laws anymore
you don't have an equal playing field
that the law guarantees
we're not saying that we want to change
the rules we're saying enforce the rules
as you have stated them and if not be
honest about what the real rules are
tell us what you're doing tell us how
you're enforcing it don't wait until
it's a senate inquiry or a facebook
whistleblower though i will tell you
people are coming out of the woodwork to
talk about what's going on
and it's only getting worse yeah crowder
as a guy that's been doing this forever
don't you kind of
admire the elegance of their evil in a
certain way like oh yeah i i have no
doubt that you see the same things that
i see like there are certain weeks
when they let my videos be seen like
you're out there we're getting the
normal numbers
or twitter you know suddenly i can get
thousands of retweets on
everything and then there's suddenly a
week where i'm purging followers and
i get five retweets on something like
that that
sort of elegance by design of just
keeping us all on our toes constantly
so that we can't be like oh there's the
smoking gun because every freaking week
something else happens yeah uh no game
has to respect game when you look at me
like okay kind of like right now with
the merrick garland like remember me i'm
like
ah that's one for you okay all right
fair play uh no you're absolutely right
i mean listen the reason that we haven't
been hurt
uh on youtube for example with traffic
so
uh this is separate from facebook is
because we know
that you can be beholden to algorithms
to search to browse to suggest it and so
we plug every time we do a show look
just tune in
monday through thursday 10 a.m eastern
we've set a schedule that's not
something that's really typical of
online content doing it live at a set
time
a good portion of our traffic comes from
people just bookmarking the page
so that we aren't in matt drudge before
he went you know who met judges today
uh he said don't be beholden to these
social media ghettos now
that doesn't mean that everybody else
has had to come up with contingency plan
over contingency plan for their business
model
but we have we've always had to try and
look around those corners so
the fact that we have for example the
fact that we have uh
you know millions of people tuning into
these shows on on on youtube
um doesn't that's not necessarily
because we're showing up in browser
suggested all the time it's because
we have planned for this this this
scenario
where we are never suggested and so
we've had to act accordingly
and uh listen that makes us more
competitive and i think that
conservatives in general are pretty
pretty industrious i don't know about
the top 10 but i can tell you what
traffic we were getting at facebook once
upon a time
versus now i can tell you how often we
were trending versus now i can only tell
you about my experience
and then i'd like to compare notes with
facebook but uh they don't answer at all
ever period yeah period it's like well
google i mean if you were to forget us
right like forget us the guys that do
this for a living but if the average
person had a problem with their gmail
account
who are you gonna call right like
there's no there's no phone number
yeah i'm sure nobody you can wojitsky
will get right on that
yeah yeah yeah they'll she'll be all
over it
um does any of this just seem like
the obvious end game of where all
of the kind of social justice lunacy
that you and i have been screaming about
for years
was gonna go in other words that these
companies have
chosen the social justice ideology
they've chosen the equity ideology
they've chosen to have you know their
board have a certain amount of trans
people and gay people about
and guys like you and i we rail against
this stuff so it's like
this shouldn't surprise us right that
they would try to go after someone like
you
um no it doesn't surprise me i've always
sort of had a target on my back that
doesn't surprise me
what does surprise me is the flagrant
disregard for
like bill was laying out just basic uh
honest business practices you know i
mean if you change the rules let us know
i don't think we violated any rules with
the election stream i mean
so so bill what what if they're just
like okay so like the the lawsuit moves
forward there's a little bit of
discovery and they're like oh yeah turns
out
you know some of some random engineer
did actually click a
switch but we're not going to do that
anymore is that enough for you guys like
what's the goal of the lawsuit a random
guide accounts payable
and a random guy at legal counsel who
doesn't end there's a lot of random guys
over there you know that's the thing it
would have to be
you know 30 different strange
coincidences
all the way across many years and across
many different departments you would
have to have just literally had every
single person
screw up continuously which is why i
said again one of their
ultimate defenses might just be we're
really really bad at everything that we
do which would completely be against
everything they say in their quarterly
stockholder statements so you know when
you're talking to your shareholders and
you're telling about what your company
is and how you do it
we're all we're asking for these types
of disclosures and really when it comes
down to the relief the first thing is
stop doing what you're doing stop saying
that your policies are a
and then actually enforcing b and if
they say well you know we're not doing
that we point all the way back to 2016
of the pattern
and here's one of the things that's
really interesting it's not something
that
is different from what they have done in
other ways they've done it with app
creators where they've said
come come and join us come and look at
our platform come make these things
create your games create your apps that
people are going to be very very excited
about and we'll give you all of this
data then all of a sudden they decide
cut the data stream charge more right
make you buy ads
again all of that is what it comes down
to as a bait and switch if you've got a
platform and you've got a business
just be open about it but if your
business model is premised on tricking
creators into putting content on your
system to get their followers to come
and then you shuttle those followers
to the ads using the data that you got
from them under a false premise
consumers and creators are all being
duped and i will say this look one thing
that i'll stand by is
uh i'm not the most talented guy in the
world but everyone kind of knows that i
have a reputation in this industry of
being a clydesdale more than uh more
than a show horse
i really do work really hard i've always
tried to stay on top of understanding
how these platforms work and i've really
had to learn how these algorithms work
and when it's based on performances
look there's a reason that these people
approached me and assigned a one-to-one
person to manage the accounts and say
hey
we'd like you to run these ads when
youtube sorry when facebook launched uh
this is a funny story you tell me if i'm
saying anything i can't say facebook
launched show pages for a while right
where was like show pages because they
wanted people to be
they wanted because they wanted to
compete with youtube and you remember
this a lot of people out there out there
outside of the industry don't know this
if you post a youtube link on facebook
doesn't get seen right
it really has to bust through because
that's competitive to facebook right
they have their video player we we were
there we
we saw when that changed so at one point
they were creating show
pages where they were saying okay which
video content is doing really well where
we just sort of want to draft in
and claim success for these successful
uh video endeavors
um and they wanted to then put these
videos and wanted to format facebook so
that these show pages would show up in
timelines
uh kind of give it favorability well
they reached out to me directly and we
had several conversations we're like
well look we see look the numbers are
impressive and we really like how you
[ __ ] and then
the second they watch the content they
said oh yeah no you're not eligible for
a show page
so when it was just based on numbers on
paper right they wanted me to do a show
page
same thing with you know with youtube
advertising where they've come and
they've set up account managers say hey
we want to come in and show you how to
advertise and you know what could you
teach us
because we don't know how you're getting
these kinds of interaction rates
literally interaction rates and i just
say you know what it is it's content
that people want to see
there's no trick i don't have any tricks
to advertising it's
just getting it in front of people look
when content like this
uh and a lot of conservative content i
would imagine gets in front of people
it wins we have an interaction rate on
google to give you an idea where
when you can skip an ad you know on
youtube before a video um all we ever
did was just
run my videos as pre-roll ads
no advertising we have an interaction
rate of over 50 percent meaning 50
didn't click skip ad that blew my mind i
click skip at it even if it's a movie
trailer for a film i want to watch
just out of muscle memory or principle i
still don't know the answer
and they go can you tell us what you're
doing because they've never seen it
that shows you the power of the ideas
and when i were when the loud earthquake
show has just been a number on a piece
of paper
or on their computer no one really uses
paper anymore uh maybe they do i have no
idea it seems like they like killing
trees
but they say okay let's look at the
pages that are doing the best so that we
can claim success
for this endeavor with our new show page
or with our advertising sort of
targeting
um they've always reached out to me when
they find out what i'm about
line goes quiet this this dave is
actually not just limited to steven i
mean
any page you know maybe maybe folks who
aren't as big as a dave rubin have
they're doing it personally they're
getting the email from the ad account
folks
and the show page folks that are saying
hey come create more content hey spend
some money on ads
this is how the ads are going to work
this is how you're going to reach people
if you do these things you're going to
get it
and and all we're saying is that you're
putting that facebook is putting a thumb
on the scale but
not telling you that the thumb is there
right back that's what it was in 2016
that's what it's been in 2018 19 and 20
and that's what we're seeing today
so bill you hit something before that i
think might be the answer here that i'm
sure you're working on which is that
if you could just get the shareholders
or or the board but i guess the
shareholders more
to see this stuff and go whoa actually
our shares are worth less because we're
discriminating against or suppressing
whatever you want to call it guys like
crowder
and that hurts our bottom line because
those are clicks with ad dollars
associated
that it's almost like you need the
shareholders to turn on the company is
that is that part of the strategy
that's certainly something that's
important it's not part of our direct
strategy but it's one where the more
eyeballs and ears that are seeing what's
going on behind the scenes
anyone who has an interest in facebook
is going to go why are you
limiting this particular content but one
of the reasons that might be a financial
reason
is because of the fact that there are so
many media companies that are these ad
buyers they're the ones that are
actually
paying facebook and generating all the
revenues where are those companies based
where are your nbc universals base where
are your viacom is based where are your
disney's based
and who are the type of people making
decisions there and that gets back to a
point that you made
about whether or not the the wokeness
lunacy that's going on and
all of the different social justice
warrior issues if that's the pressure
it's it is
highly ironic that companies that often
rail against capitalism
will use capitalism to force other
companies
to hurt smaller companies that's really
what's happening here and that's the
media company telling another media
company hurt another media company
because we don't like them
and i think it was nits never like bill
has said it's never been a plan of this
strategy it sort of was accidental with
the vox apocalypse though remember we
found out afterwards we're like why are
they
reaching out to us turns out that
alphabet took a nosedive their stock
after the vox apocalypse
because a lot of people were upset and
you know sometimes the market puts
people between a rock and a hard place
where it's
okay either appease the people who work
in your pal in your northern california
offices
or piss off half of the most powerful
nation on earth
right and that's where they often find
themselves crowder when that
adpocalypse thing happened and it had a
lot to do with you got into a little
skirmish with this carlos mazza guy
from from vox who happened to be the
same guy
who lobbied pete bootage to not do my
show
and you know runs around calling
everyone white supremacists
and and the rest of it does that
asymmetry drive you nuts that
they can say whatever they want about us
all the time we know that and they can
do whatever damage they want to our
businesses
but then and i uh correct me if i'm
wrong but i'm pretty sure he's like a
you know like a privileged partner or
whatever they call it on youtube
while he can say whatever he wants about
us but if we were to do the same with
him
you you lost your ad rev for what a year
on youtube
more than a year right i don't know
exactly what it was i will tell you this
though to be fair um
i never really focused on on that guy
and i hate to correct you but really
this was just one of or several videos
in a series of criticisms of vox you
know vox would do their explain series
so we criticize vox all the time just
like we do with john oliver just like we
do with vice
just like we would do a slate and uh
this was really kind of edited out of
context what it was for me
my problem there was nbc universal
vox one of the most powerful companies
in the world who also happen to have a
lot of advertising
uh dollars that they spend with a
company like youtube
trying to get the independent content
creator removed and by the way also they
co-produce a show um youtube and
and vox um along with there's licensing
agreements with netflix so
for me it was really important and i
think this resonated with people as
opposed to individuals
um it was a david versus goliath where
it's like look it's easy to say hey
we have a big following and a big show
but we've built this over
years and nbc universal vox is trying to
take that away because
they were late to the party they wanted
to keep everything off of youtube we
were there when they were copyright
claiming everything
and not putting anything on youtube and
then they wanted to compete and not to
you know listen i i hate to do this with
fox news but i was at fox news for four
and a half years
my own interviews that i would do on fox
news at this point i may be at 50 000
subscribers on youtube
were removed when i would ask hey can i
upload them i said sure and they said
you know what we actually don't want
these things going on youtube because we
don't think it has the longevity
and now of course you see it's one of
the very few conservative outlets
that's consistently featured on youtube
because they have that buying power
and they're trying to play catch up this
is really about legacy media
um being behind the eight ball and
making up for it with dollars
and what we would what i would like to
see this isn't this doesn't relate to
our legal case but
um this relates to the ecosystem look
youtube will never be netflix
and if they want to understand their
business model and how they survive
it's not by letting legacy media try and
corporatize youtube right
it's by focusing on and supporting their
content creators
but all of these you know turner nbc
universal
disney abc there's really about five
companies
they will do anything they can to remove
competition
what's brian stelter gonna do compete
with you compete with me
honestly i still want i still want to
know what that guy did to get a show
chris cuomo
his brother's governor good-looking guy
brian stelter is untalented unattractive
and uninformed and he gets a show
with no experience well what's what's
gonna that's why that guy
more aggressively than any other on-air
host lobbies
to have people removed and de-platformed
on a regular basis it's because they're
afraid of competition
so do you think you could ever get to
the the point of popularity numbers
monetization whatever you want to call
it that you would just be like
all right i i don't want to do the legal
route anymore we're not getting anywhere
or it's a strain and stress and
everything else and
i'm i'm just going to be free meaning
i'll be on the blaze
or whatever else there might be um and
just not deal
with this nonsense i could probably do
that
now in the sense that if i just were
just talking about surviving and keeping
my people employed
i could probably do that now because we
have a lot of people who support us and
who join up with
with mug club um but uh we've always
said that we want to make sure that
um you know the supported content is
what uh
allows the free content you know for me
my goal is always to have as many people
out there
who at least are whether or not they're
conservative uh
free speech advocates you know for me
i'm a simple guy i am pretty
pretty right wing but first amendment
second amendment especially coming from
a country that
has neither canada are pretty important
to me to give you an analogy and i've
always talked about this where i'm
i'm big into firearms but i'm not a
collector i'm not a maven what i would
rather see out there
are 50 people with one firearm than one
person with 50.
i want more people comfortable around
firearms those who've taken basic
firearm safety courses who
understand how firearms work because
once that happens you know you can no
longer have joe biden go up and say uh
an
ar-14 is a sim is a machine gun first
off you meant ar-15 not 14 and it's not
a machine gun it's a semi-automatic just
like any other handgun
so for me it's really important to be on
youtube and be on facebook and be on
twitter
to reach new people and to create new
free speech advocates and new
firearm owners new conservatives people
who will understand what this country
was
was founded on and and continue those
values forward so could i leave take my
ball and go home and
and and make enough to live comfortably
with the people who will support us
probably but we're not going to be
reaching any new hearts and minds so for
as long as i can be on those platforms
and even if i'm just a thorn in their
side uh that's a good thing that tells
me that we're reaching a lot of folks
yeah i'm with you bill what about just
the the culture of fear
around lawyers i i sort of hit on this
earlier but just when
when you're talking to your colleagues
or other people at your firm or
or just when you're talking to crowders
fans i mean
you got to be somewhat afraid that
they're going to bust into all your
emails and
whatever else whatever else we can think
they can do and probably what's worse is
the stuff that we can't imagine they can
do
there's certainly a concern about that i
do get a lot of communications from
folks i think the ones that are the
the most damning of where we've come as
a culture
is when i get emails from law schools
across the country from law students
and i get instagram messages and tweets
and sometimes calls and they're just
like
wow i can't say anything about this i
can't remotely show that i'm
conservative there are few that are
willing to do it and they pay the price
for it
i'm just going to get my degree work
quietly and move along the number of
folks who
you know i show up and they go oh wow
they sent me an email i go i didn't even
realize that you were conservative you
just never came up in
committee meetings or organization
meetings or at a you know bar
function or whatnot and because of that
culture of fear and
it to a certain extent you just have to
say it's okay
i'm gonna accept whatever might come
that come down that pike and
deal with it because you know when
you're dealing with these companies
that's certainly going to happen
you know fortunately for me we've got a
broad base of different clients and
different folks who are supportive and
and really just say great lawyers i
don't care let's hire them let's go get
it done
i think the folks like steven have to
really step out on a limb and have
along with other folks who are even
willing to talk about these types of
things
knowing that all of the strings are
controlled uh out of menlo park and palo
alto
and you know what on that note you know
for example um gina quran i can say this
now because it's public
look i've known this for a very long
time about gina carrano gina kranos
followed me we've invited gina carrano
on the show and she has
watched the show i i can't do it so now
i think we'll probably have in the show
and by the way she
decided to appear on ben shapiro show
but one thing ben shapiro can't claim is
an actual teenage crush on gina karen i
was a brown belt in jujitsu people know
i come by it honestly
and i used to watch every single gina
carano fight including her getting
manhandled by cyborg who tested positive
for steroids where effectively dean
corinna was fighting a man not named
fallon fox but i digress wait hold on
hold on you're saying
ben shapiro is not a brown belt in jiu
jitsu
shapiro didn't know gina carrano until
this happened unless he's a star wars
nerd
i followed gina carrano when she was
fighting
in the fight uh but i can tell you right
now
off the top of my head i could give you
another eight to ten gina karanos
actually
and some other people including people
in the sport of mma including people who
would be
current top ten paid in hollywood
who would never come out and i would
never out them they're still out there
but i can tell you gina carrano was one
of them and i i certainly hope that we
have on the show
but that's so sad to me because the
thing about gina karano i think this was
a bigger story
than people even realized because yeah
you have a lot of people have been d
platformed
but there are a lot of sort of
conservatives who guilty
uh abrasive and they're easier to hate i
think when people actually tune in to
what we do they understand that
people sort of go well this is actually
basic [ __ ] conservatism is the heart in
this is really not malicious at all
but gina carrano was the first example
of someone who was not really outwardly
political
and nothing she said in
any capacity could be interpreted as
malicious there was no malice
to any of it as a matter of fact and i
think that generally speaking
uh holocaust or hitler comparisons are
ill-advised
i think she was as thoughtful and as
tactful with that post
as one could be because she wasn't
saying it's like being a jew being a
conservative
uh in hollywood which she was saying is
it started by having your neighbors
snitch on neighbors and i think that's
the important thing people use this term
sort of cancel culture
and it didn't exist by the way i pitched
the book for change my mind i've talked
about this many times to conservative
publishers
and there was no canceled culture so i
had these but i described sjws
i described leftist activists and i
described people who were sort of
liberal by default and sort of
what ended up becoming the alt-right and
i just had different words for it and
every single publisher turned it down
and said this book is silly no one will
ever want to do it
change my mind book um but what's so
crazy about this i don't want to say
crazy what really makes me sad
is when people say good good for good
for gina carrano being removed and you
look at the content
of what it is that she said that's
people saying good i hope you
never have the ability to provide for
your family again
this is desensitizing people this could
easily be desensitizing people
towards something much more sinister not
saying it is not saying that's part of
some
some conspiracy plan but when people are
saying
cancel that person and they're
supporting it they're supporting the
ending
of people's livelihoods which by the way
is exactly what they're doing
with covet lockdowns and businesses and
saying how much is your life worth
hold on a second you're talking about a
0.17
whatever it is death rate which by the
way is the exact number that those
california doctors were
banned for communicating on facebook and
youtube because at that point it was the
imperial college of london saying
it was a two to four percent death rate
hold on a second you're saying how much
is my life worth because
we have 60 percent of businesses now
that have been that'll be open in april
that won't be open in september
right how much is a livelihood worth
people right now are so quick to go
along
with removing someone's ability to
provide for their family
forever and if you get people okay with
that i don't think it's that much of a
leap to say that you get opaque
you get desensitized to dehumanizing
people um
to any degree yeah you know i actually i
was away uh when the whole genocidal
thing happened last week so i didn't
address it on the show but i'm
completely with you just for the record
crowder like there was nothing remotely
anti-semitic or anti-jewish
or anything like that that she said she
was actually making a pretty thoughtful
point and the irony of course is the
people that were trying to destroy her
they call everybody nazis which would be
a far worse
cultural appropriation or or labeling
than anything she did
bill go ahead there's a little bit of a
frog in hot water right the whole
analogy if you throw the
frog into hot water he'll jump out but
if you just turn the heat up you
desensitize the frog he'll stay in there
and boil to death
and that's what we're looking at right
now a couple episodes you talked about
a cnn reporter who was able to say oh
well under the first amendment you can't
lie
and you eviscerate you had a great
argument about why that was wrong but
you made a really good point you
actually made two points one
expressly one implicitly you said she's
wrong
we should let her know that she's wrong
now i'm not saying cancel or anything
like that
and that's the way you engage in a
respectful communication
you can be harsh and critical about
someone saying something incorrect
especially a legal correspondent on a
national news network but you can also
say
that doesn't mean we're erasing her from
her business from her livelihood or
anything like that you made that
subconsciously it's built into your
value system
to say i'm not going to engage in
cancelled culture but calling people out
is the important part
and that's part of what the important
part of staying on youtube and being
able to call these
these platforms out about what they're
doing and how they've converted
themselves into publishers how they've
converted themselves
into being editors and content creators
themselves
and gotten all the way around 230 is to
be able to say hey
we have other voices and people want to
hear those other voices just play by the
rules
right and when they say these rules are
being enforced equally they say
regardless of political viewpoint
that's a really clever thing right they
just did this recently with uh to use a
non-political example pewdiepie and
what's that kid's channel i don't know
but in other words it was a selective
enforcement of satire it was a diss
track
uh on youtube aimed at a kid's channel
and they said we believe that this
violates our guidelines
um when they say these are applied
equally regardless of point of view well
hold on a second
when you say that these are applied
equally and by the way
if you say that you believe people can't
change their biological sex
which is a medical fact we're not
talking about gender year or gender
theory
judas butler symond above war they say
well that's a violation of our
guidelines
there is no way to apply that equally
because you've eliminated
anyone who has an opinion different from
yours that's the point
we for example we had one video on
youtube where i was doing it changed my
mind
and there was a male to female trans
person
very newly male to female trans person
by the way meaning like that day
who um assaulted me and threw a homeless
man's lunch box
at me and then we did a play-by-play and
we laughed
at the way this trans male to female
ran away in z's high heels because it
was funny
and that was considered more offensive
than stealing a homeless man's lunchbox
and throwing it at me and by the way i
don't even think i was talking about
genders at that point i think i was
talking about male privilege
so this is to say that that's applied
equally there's no way to apply that
equally
the deck is stacked from the get-go with
those rules and then you go a step
further
where with facebook they haven't even
clarified what the rules
are or what the violation is so we know
that based on the publicly available
guidelines with companies like youtube
and i would say they do a better
job than facebook to give them credit
there that it's not really applied
equally
and then when you don't have them
publicly available and they don't give
any rationalization for removing content
look maybe you think you're maybe you're
out there and you think that facebook is
right
how do you know we don't know if we
think they're right
we can't nobody is right so that gets to
my point earlier
about how social justice critical race
theory all of
all of these bad ideas that have now
infected all of these companies
they're in direct combat or conflict
with reality so when you say that there
are biological differences between
men and women which everyone knows to be
true every biologist knows that to be
true
but that doesn't fit in with the sjw
thing that these companies have now put
into
their terms of service they've put into
the way they behave with their boards
and everywhere else
it's almost like this this is a totally
intractable
problem because their reality actually
is different than
the reality that we've known for
thousands of years
you know what's funny though is actually
i will say this with the and the people
say why do you focus on the trans issue
so much well i will say this because
as a christian conservative i believe
when you say that there that that
uh there is no fundamental difference at
all between men and women that
men and women are completely
interchangeable i think that's a real
problem for our civilization i think
it's a real
it's a real problem if we're not saying
that hey there are moms there are dads
there are boys there are girls because
you raise them differently not only that
you support them differently as a
community you find out how to help them
differently
but i will say this there is something
kind of funny we were talking about this
earlier
on my program this morning about how
things that you would say
uh would be considered uh toxically
masculine
or patriarchal or be considered
anti-woman uh
unless it's trans so for example you
know the 55 year old
the 50 year old man who's playing
college basketball
in the girls league or fallon fox uh who
lived as a man and fathered children
into his 30s and then you know
beat up women identifying as a female
when you read their stories what they
say is
you know what when i came when i came
out to my teammates you're six foot
eight 245 pounds by the way i think i
don't think that
i think they deserve an academy award if
you think you were coming out but they
said
my teammates never knew this i was just
reading this today on air my teammates
never knew this because
my level of endurance strength my lung
capacity
i was the same as other women well hold
on a second what are you implying there
or if you look at a lot of the times
what a trans male to female is
well it's really perpetuation of these
unrealistic beauty standards it's
usually someone dressing like a barbie
with a blonde wig and
over-the-top makeup right and usually
they end up getting uh breast implants
these are things that are thought of as
toxic masculine stereotypes until you
say well i'm trans and people didn't
know
because i'm weaker i'm smaller i'm
slower i don't have the same lung
capacity but look at my blonde wig and
makeup right that's what a woman is
it distills both sexes to the
stereotypes that we're supposed to
reject
only now we have to embrace as a part of
this very very new by the way
uh sort of gender experiment and i think
that that's also really important as it
relates to the speech guidelines online
because when you effectively are saying
that half of the medical community
are not allowed to voice an opinion that
your rules are being applied equally
then i just disagree as to what equally
means
and then of course we get back to the
idea of facebook where they don't even
say what what it is we still have no
w what what happened with the stream was
it gone it's gone just give me an answer
and dave on that point i mean when you
look at the rules themselves and the way
they've been set out
even the very basic statement of saying
you know we won't allow hate or
harassment
based on race religion uh political
ideology and you say okay so you're not
allowed to make fun of
white male christians okay got it all
right is that is that wait do they say
political ideology i'd be shocked if
that's
in there so they used to say political
ideology and then in 2016 they actually
gave statements to the senate saying we
don't actually do it
and that was the thing that they
trumpeted everywhere because it wasn't
in their particular rules but they were
being called out about it and they said
no no no no no in case anyone is
concerned we do not do that
i mean it's in the response letter it's
in their articles multiple spokespersons
said
we do not do that and that is the thing
that they have advertised
ever since and they even say it now you
have mark zuckerberg saying no
senator we do not engage in any kind of
ideological
you know considerations we do not
suppress conservatives and i'm not
saying they suppress
every single conservative no that's not
that's not a hill anyone needs to die on
it's a question about individual voices
and what they're doing and the rules as
they have them but how do you define
these things
they can't define them and yet in the
end the creators are the ones that are
abused because of it and by the way this
is just as much for liberals as it is
for conservatives
i mean keep in mind look this is
something also to consider when people
said donald trump was anti-press
he had the power of the executive i was
actually disappointed that donald trump
didn't do more on section 230
didn't do anything to actually get
anybody oh yeah he revoked some people's
press pass because they asked some
dishonest questions for a day and a half
think about it i don't want if there's a
republican in power
i want that that potential tyranny
regardless of who's willing that power
to have some checks and balances
this is just as much for future liberals
because i don't want them to be removed
from the platform
outside of criminality meaning actually
calling
for violence or physical harm to people
right these are things that we have laws
for these things
um this is just as much for for liberals
as it is for conservatives it's just
really hard for liberals right now to
see that
because they even even though donald
trump was president for four years and
even during that time they see
themselves as the ones in power
because you have really three to five
companies who are more powerful
than any national government that has
ever existed in the world before today
and that's facebook twitter
alphabet apple amazon so does that worry
you or does that push your
your libertarian stuff to to the end
because
i mean you know my i agree with you on
that and it's like if you're breaking
the laws of the united states then you
got a bigger problem than the platforms
because then
the government's going to go after you
so that should clean up most
of that um but but you hear you know
there were all these conservatives
saying oh trump had to do something
trump had to do something
and now i still hear some of them saying
it but it's like wait a minute i thought
you hate biden so now you want the
government involved even though it's not
your guy anymore like
it sort of just basically flipped
everybody's beliefs on top of themselves
my position has always been very
consistent whereas i just want the first
step
is them deciding i want them to publicly
declare if they're a platform
if they want to be treated as such or a
publisher because they're kind of
benefiting from
both sets of rules right now and you
have to pick one right
either you are liable for the kind of
content on your platform in which case
you can take these uh for you can take
these actions which they take which act
uh beyond the law and in some cases by
the way don't even follow the law
because there's a different set of
online law to give you an idea here
um you know we had it for a long time in
this country
okay uh an idea of what investigative
journalism was
that no longer exists it no longer
exists because
first off we have single party consent
laws youtube and facebook don't
necessarily
follow those laws so you can say okay
we're finding someone who's a corrupt
member of congress or you know
a senator or running for president for
example and
uh we're in a single party consent state
which means that legally i have the
right to record this conversation
and i catch them in an act that is
deliberately
harmful right that is deliberately
manipulative something like that i mean
for example the access hollywood tape
you can follow all these laws and it can
be removed because
youtube says they want to it can be
removed as we've seen on the same day
from youtube facebook twitter even
though you followed the laws and then
if you've broken the laws it can be
allowed to stay up
that is a very very scary thing we've
had this happen where we've interviewed
people
on the street right where we've and we
were already in single party consent
states
where we had the right to interview
people but had them sign release
forms to be on air with these questions
and then youtube said actually this
someone said this was a violation of
privacy so this is a public protest
well there's no reasonable expectation
of privacy and by the way we have them
if we want us to send you the form we
have them on camera confirming and
consenting they say it doesn't matter
because now the rule is if anyone ever
regrets being on camera we're going to
remove it well how wonderful that would
have been for nixon
how wonderful for anthony weiner
investigative journalism doesn't exist
anymore
and that is scary because these people
can effectively
create the laws and that determines what
you what you can and can't see
and it determines who and who is never
held accountable
yeah bill is there anything you can do
or look into on the moving goal post
portion of that so for example you know
after 2016
basically every lefty youtube channel
ran for four years and not
not just them cnn everybody ran with you
know russian collusion
he's he's a fake president hillary
clinton said he's illegitimate the whole
thing
um but you guys know that if we were to
even discuss anything about this last
election
that both of us could you could probably
get booted for being my guest right now
um is there anything you can look into
on on that
well it's certainly something that we're
going to be looking at very closely
because of the
of the fact that this case involves
fraud it's it's a question of
are you taking policies and enforcing
them one way depending on the speaker
versus the other now folks on the left
will say that's exactly what you're
supposed to do
if someone who has one skin color says
something and someone who has a
different
color says something you have to view
them as very and completely different
right that's actually a fundamental
value of certain groups in the country
who tend to be
lobbying these political these uh
platforms and publishers about how
they're actually engaging in their in
their business
but what we're saying is no your rules
say you will not treat the speaker
differently
based on who the speaker is of their
characteristic and that's the rule that
we're trying to say so
of course we're going to be looking at
saying well why did you decide to let
this content stay up
but yet you took this other content down
because you said that it was hateful or
harassing or going against
a certain race or religion or whatever
it may be where you thought that it was
not speaking uh
exactly how you should speak about kovid
or wasn't parroting
the current version this week about what
the who is saying the rules are on masks
or vaccines and you go and you find
those hypocritical examples
every one of those is absolutely
relevant to not only our
lawsuit but it's very relevant to all of
the state governors
and attorney generals who are going
after google
facebook and the other platforms based
on their anti-competitive antitrust
lawsuits that are going out there right
now
bill let me ask you something else
before i let steven jump back in
on the legal side i mean i'm a firm
believer at this point you know i'm in
crazy la california right now
we don't know for how much longer but at
least as we're recording this
um that that lawsuits are going to be
what
what actually turns this country around
which i i hate to say
although it probably sounds good as a
lawyer that that it will ultimately be
suing
gavin newsom it will be suing andrew
cuomo
and getting all of the stuff on
discovery that will show that there was
no science behind lockdowns and the
arbitrary decisions they made and it was
much more about politics
than everything else do you see that as
the way that we get out of this
this endless half state of lockdown that
we're in
it is it's going to be that way it's
going to be your investigations of cuomo
it's going to be your investigations in
a variety of different states it's
it's looking into what was said publicly
and this cuts both ways i mean this is
really important to say we're talking
about universal principles here
that cut across all ideologies being
pro-business but being anti-fraud
requiring businesses to give adequate
disclosures
when you're a politician saying the
truth based on the information you have
maybe you're mistaken people get
mistakes all the time governments make
mistakes all the time
didn't mean to say the n-word e-r clear
as day
but he did it and you own up to those
mistakes right and then you
live with the consequences fortunately
we do live in a country that says
that we will allow this to happen
however there is a dangerous precedent
being set right now and you kind of
talked about it earlier which is a
canceled culture as it relates to even
the legal field
right whether or not certain lawyers or
law firms should not be allowed to do it
because of who they voted for
or the positions that they espoused and
again we're not talking about
crazy policies we already have laws in
place we already have disciplinary rules
in place that have worked for decades
and decades and decades but to now say
well wait a minute
i don't really like their voting record
i don't really like the policies that
they're talking about
so now they can't even bring a lawsuit
now they can't even show up in court
who is going to represent the
individuals who are saying wait a minute
these companies need to do something
different look we have no qualms about
the fact that there's going to be an
uphill battle
between california federal court a
california-based uh
court of appeals and eventually having
to get to the supreme court we know that
that's going to be the case
we know that the misinterpretation of
section 230 which is titled
good samaritan it says you have to have
a good faith basis
for removing the content in order to
have liability not a complete
blanket of saying well we woke up today
and we decided to just cancel this
entire page
that's how it's being interpreted right
now and we know that this is the only
way that it's going to happen i still
have full confidence in
exercising the legal remedies that we
have in this system
if for some reason and i'm guessing
right now it's not going to happen
that the legislature doesn't get
something congress doesn't get something
done
to change it whether it's biden whether
it's trump whether it's the candidate in
2024
whether it's any candidate in any
congress whether it's center of the
house
the everyone needs to come down with
these universal values of saying that
businesses
need to be held liable when they're
violating laws not have blanket
protection like
is currently being interpreted and
simply can't engage in rampant
ongoing fraud of every person who's on
these platforms and he's something you
know i was just
sorry what are those cayman what are
those boots those shoes i don't know
stamp leather he's wearing some spiffy
shoes sorry dave i got distracted by his
shoes
i have two points to make i want you to
go first well i was gonna say that uh
as you were laying that out though it
reminds me of years ago when when all of
the nonsense started with youtube very
early on and i
finally got a contact i'm sure crowder
you remember at first when you finally
get a human being there somehow
and i get somebody yeah and you finally
get an email address
and somebody actually said whoever the
youtube partner
manager was whatever you want to call
him said because i kept saying hey you
know i'm getting these emails every day
and hundreds of tweets every day
people are being unsubscribed from my
channel so they said in an email i still
have the email they said oh well
after weeks we looked into it and there
is a bug on your channel and we're going
to see what we can do now then
of course i don't hear from them for a
month or two finally right back
and then i got an a form letter email
saying this person
no longer works in this department and
you can do everything through the
you know just like the manual submission
thing and that was it so
bill that gets to your point about you
know how they how they decide
okay you got a human now you got a robot
crowd or take it away
bring us home here crowder i was going
to say a couple of things here
first off i understand your point as a
libertarian i have a little bit of a
different point of view
um on on lawsuits i do think that we're
an overly
litigious country but i think there's a
difference between
being an actual ambulance chaser uh
who's cheating on
your wife on her deathbed with a
pregnant woman like john edwards uh
versus did i just i just found this out
yesterday
um my uncle remo uh who uh uh
jean-guitar is largely based on
french canadian he was we just i just
found out yesterday that he has um
pretty advanced kidney cancer he's going
to have to have it removed but he's had
it since
july do you know why they didn't tell
him
his papers fell between the desk
this is quebec socialized healthcare now
tell me that's not
that's not a lawsuit that's legitimate
at that point you're talking about
seven months of cancer advancing because
you dropped the papers
between the desk that's what happened
there is really no recourse in canada
and of course the quality of care is
nowhere near as it is here so his you
know the actual mortality rates are
higher to begin with
so i do think that you know lawsuits are
are a form of checks and balances that
are important in this country
i also think it's important for people
to understand you know um the burden
where was our where was our disagreement
on that though because i'm with you on
that no i know
i know you were saying that as a
libertarian you know you you don't you'd
hate to say that you know those
solutions are with lawsuits
i know we were coming from because i
think that you know we probably support
things like tort reform and i think that
there are a lot of lawsuits out there
where the system is abused
but i do think uh coming from canada
where really there there are often
very few legal recourses as it relates
to business
that i actually see that is a wonderful
thing when applied appropriately here in
the united states
i think something else that's important
you talked about the election um
as far as i know these are youtube's not
as far as i know i've read them in depth
uh youtube's guidelines are you can talk
about voter fraud
well thank god because otherwise
elizabeth warren and amy klobuchar would
be banned from youtube so would jimmy
carter
you can say that there's even been voter
fraud to um large
levels what you can't what you cannot
say
is that it in any way affected the
outcome
of this election to give you an idea as
to the burden of proof requirement that
has put on conservatives at this point
because there have been a lot of people
who've been banned simply for talking
about the election
um i have gone on air and and half asian
bill knows this
i've only made claims about things that
i've actually gone through voter rolls
when i say that there are addresses in
this election for example in nevada in
michigan
from people who don't actually exist or
addresses that weren't there
i actually had to send my staff
or myself go there and take pictures
at the empty lot under an overpass these
are addresses where people voted from
or on a construction site with a picture
of today's newspaper and we'll have a
video coming out so when i say i make
these claims under penalty of perjury
what does a lib what does the new york
times have to say what does the what do
the young turks have to say what is it
they just say there is no evidence of
voter fraud really
what do diligence have you done and
that's the issue right there it's when
you require
me to fly on my own dime or send an
intern on my
own time to go take pictures with
today's newspaper
just so that i can make a claim that we
know is verifiably true
and there is no requirement for research
sources due diligence on any of the
leftists you show me any of these
programs that abc nbc cbs msnbc
any of the online ones like young trucks
who list all of their sources as we do
any day with every single show you may
disagree with me
every now and then you may say you know
what that's not the best source that's
actually not the best study that comes
from pubmed i have a more effective
meta-analysis sure but it's not even
asked of the left to do that work that's
not a level playing field
crowder i know everyone knows where to
find it we'll include the links down
below
if if people want to help you guys or if
they have any insight or info or they're
whistleblowers or whatever else there is
is there anywhere that they can contact
you bill i'm sure you want to hear from
all of my youtube commenters all the
stuff that they know
whistleblowers contact chelsea
underscore manning at
louderwithcrowder.com
and uh we have them sorting through no
actually uh you can always join mud club
loudercutter.com
mug club and people can obviously watch
us there on the blaze i think we have
fight like hell as a promo code people
get thirty dollars off where is the best
place for if there's someone so
so we have a lot of folks who are coming
in through the life advice email
and life advice at lotterycrowder.com
and and look
this is an important kind of perhaps
final point which is
the the necessary evil that it comes
with lawyers right
if lawyers if people were just good to
each other if businesses didn't commit
fraud
you wouldn't need the large amount of
lawyers that you have today and that's
unfortunate that we have to rely on that
because the government and the congress
hasn't stepped in
to fix section 230. they haven't the
courts haven't done what they needed to
do to interpret that in the correct way
and it is a thing that we have to do but
ultimately one of the most important
things that is going to change
is people who are deciding to move with
their eyeballs and ears to different
platforms
it's these other nascent platforms that
are growing that
ultimately folks are going to go wait a
minute those shareholders we talked
about earlier are going to go
why is everyone leaving why can't we
just be an open platform
why do we have policies that no one
understands that we enforce
indiscriminately
that's going to maybe be the thing that
changes it faster than
a four-year slog to the supreme court
back down and years and years of
discovery these companies have the money
to be able to do that
but if the country wants to go in the
right direction the consumers have to do
something and the government has to as
well
i think it goes without saying i'm in
the fight with you guys so
anything i can do let me know bill
richmond
thanks for being on the show and crowder
it was april 2016. that's four years in
10 min 10 months
i'm thinking we'll do the next one four
years eight months i felt like you
brought it today
that's fair enough that's fair enough i
hate myself too dave
all right thanks guys good luck if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about
comedy instead of the non-stop yelling
you get everywhere else check out our
comedy playlist and if you want to watch
full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out our full episode playlist they're
both
right over here and to get notified of
all future videos be sure to subscribe
and click the notification bell